David's thanks to come on the show it's
an important moment of remembrance
I wanted to ask you to start off with it
for your family it's not an abstract
though is it this day it's a central
event in the story of your family and
where you come from can you tell me fast
about your family and your mum's early
life yeah so my mom was born in 1939 in
Nazi Germany in a place called
koenigsberg which is no longer in
Germany after the war it became Russian
and became kalinian grad and I actually
went there when I did who do you think
you are for the BBC
and by the time my mother was born my
grandfather who had been a successful
man in koenigsberg he'd built he ran a
brick Factory he was an industrialist
you know he was doing well but by that
time
um the Nuremberg Laws had obviously been
established and actually he himself had
been in a concentration camp because
it's not that well known but there are
some concentration camps were set up
before the war like Dachau and after
kristallnacht
um which if anyone doesn't know was not
in 1938 when Jewish businesses were
stormed by storm troopers and glass was
smashed which is why it's called that
after that many many Jews something like
300 000 Jews were arrested and taken to
these camps so my grandfather was there
uh for I don't know about a year I think
and then basically everything they had
was involved in bribing the authorities
doing anything they could to get him out
of there and with literally kind of
three weeks to go before the war having
now given birth uh to my mother as well
they managed to get out
um but they managed to get your
grandfather out my grandfather now my
grandma basically my mum came she wasn't
Kinder transported she came to this
country with both her parents but her
wider family was almost entirely
murdered in your mother did she
talk about her childhood and what it was
like does she used to talk to you about
it when you were growing up or was it
something that was painful and kept
um away my grandparents
um did talk about it but only in quite
um
broken ways
um so for example my grandmother who I
was pretty close to Otty Fabian but who
wanted to appear English because I think
she was terrified of her seeming German
and being identified as a German Jew
even after the war
um I remember asking her if she had any
other any brothers and sisters and she
said you'll have to ask Mr Hitler about
that and I remember thinking what that
they sing about on Dad's Army what are
you talking about when I was 10 I asked
this and what she meant was that there
was brothers and sisters who she didn't
know what they were she didn't know what
happened to them which is an
extraordinary thing when you think about
it just have no idea what happened to
your brother and sister it must be awful
and you can never be at peace right
because yeah there's this unfinished
never at peace my mother didn't know any
memory of Nazi Germany but there are
things about my mother that in later
life I've thought are just incredibly
painful to think about so my mother's
name was Sarah badiel that was a name
given to her by the Nazis all Jewish
females registered after 1935 had to
choose specific names from a list they
all had to have the middle name Sarah
and they had to choose their first names
from a list of really horrible names my
mum's original name was from it from it
Sarah Fabian her original name but that
was a name that she completely disavowed
it makes a lot she wouldn't hear what
the fact that her real name was from it
it actually means which is completely
wrong for my mother it means something
like
in a medieval way Pious why it's not one
of the really horrible ones I mean Pious
one which is very wrong for my mother
but it um it spoke to her of the fact
that she was given names handed down by
the Nazis my mother was an extraordinary
woman great in the thousand ways but
also really really damaged she was
really damaged and you know really
traumatized I think in ways that she
couldn't quite work out herself and even
though she came over as a baby you have
to understand the inheritance of trauma
so she grew up whether or not she
actually she got out of naughty Germany
but she grew up with two people whose
lives had been totally ripped apart
who'd lost their families had lost their
livelihood they were disenfranchised and
humiliated for many years in Nazi
Germany and then had a very unstable
life in Britain
and that means that it was really really
difficult for her to sort out who she
was and how to live her life and the
mistakes she then made are all to do
with that well how did that Cascade down
to you in your childhood or didn't you
realize at the time I don't think I
realized at the time my mother was just
that's a whole other story and she was a
complicated parent you know in ways that
I kind of celebrate because I think the
way in which she was a complicated and
strange parent have made me who I am and
I'm happy with who I am but I now see it
was all to do with her having come from
this incredibly traumatized home
background and having traumatized
parents that were then bringing her up
yeah and what about you David because
your personal experience you tell me
about your visit to Auschwitz you said
you were kind of frightened about going
when I went there yeah I was frightened
in a kind of
um
I think I was frightened in a horror
film way I just thought this is one of
the most horrific places there's ever
been uh it's gonna come home to me the
horror of hearing about it it's still
really difficult for the human
imagination to reach that place where
you think this this happened here this
unbelievable horror happened so it's not
abstract for your family no well it's
really not and that's the thing that
strikes me I mean I've also been and I
found it very disturbing
but for you it's you can think of your
great uncle or that that must be really
hard yeah what is hard I can think of my
great uncle I can also think of the
enormous amount of relatives who I've
never even met or know about so I've
seen pictures for example of my
grandparents family and they're an
extended family right there's like one
picture I've seen which has got like 50
people in it and a big family thing that
they had in kind of 1912. I don't know
the names of most of them and all I know
is that they were killed all their
children were killed it's important to
note by the way the reason we know quite
a lot about Auschwitz is that ausridge
was a labor camp and the death camp so
people survived Auschwitz not that many
but some people survived in order to
tell the tale Treblinka was just an
extermination camp chelmo was just an
extermination Campbell Shack was just an
extermination camp millions of people
died there and there were no survivors
and people don't even know the names of
these camps really do they no and so
that's also the issue is
a lot of people don't know exactly what
happened to their relatives and that can
make it very difficult we talk a lot
about closure now in our society about
getting through trauma but how do you
get through it if you can't completely
trace it am I right is thinking that you
have embraced your Jewish identity more
as you've got older that you
feel more Jewish now that you want to
know more about your family and that has
something that's evolved for you it
seems to me that it has yeah that's true
I think it's complicated for me because
as I've often said I'm an atheist which
is an important point for me because I
think people think that anti-Semitism is
a type of religious intolerance in
general it's not it's racism and you can
tell it's racism because me being an
atheist would have got me no free passes
out of Auschwitz and that's very
important but as I got older I have felt
more Jewish and in terms of the
Holocaust Memorial Day what do you want
people to be thinking about on that is
it more you want it to be acknowledged
education is the key so that people
actually know the detail of the
Holocaust there's one other thing I
think which is to do with what I talk
about in my booktube don't count which
is you know my book is about how
Progressive people to some extent
downgrade anti-Semitism amongst the
other things that they care about one
way which you see this is what you might
call Holocaust fatigue I was going to
ask you about about you what do you mean
by that well well what I perceive it as
is kind of yeah we sort of know about
the Holocaust can we move on to other
subjects and also uh I guess further on
a sense of look this is which is a
misnomer this is a white on white
tragedy which it isn't because the Nazis
classified Jews as non-white and so
therefore we need to focus on other
things because we focus too much on this
because we live in a culture that
focuses on ourselves but we need to
understand that the Holocaust still sits
at the center of all this at a
particular type of atrocity where an
ethnic group a civilian ethnic group
we're targeted by a genocidal State
machine for a long time in the years
after the war people said never again
and that it seemed to be the accepted
position never again
and scientism continue to exist but it
felt like it was on the margin spewed
out you have like crackpots and
it doesn't really feel like that today
though does it it feels Center Stage do
you do you feel that well I certainly
think it's been it's been normalized
coming from where is it coming from is
it the sort of mainstreaming of hard
white politics in the US what's it about
uh well it's a really dull answer but I
think it's the internet at heart I mean
obviously there's also other things like
the rise of populism which tends to look
for easy targets and the Jews are always
a Target and the rise of conspiracy
theory and almost all conspiracy theory
at some level comes back to it was the
Jews and economics because as the world
goes more and more into the bad economic
economic pits then again they look for
somehow or other people responsible for
that scapegoats and those are often are
the Jews but at heart I think it's the
internet because I think that
unfortunately I'm not sure anti-Semitism
ever went away we now have sort of
celebrity anti-Semitism the form of
Kanye West right how how trouble Were
You by that and how cross were you with
the likes of Elon Musk for giving a guy
a platform again in which he can put
this stuff out I kind of feel just sad
sad about it and my approach to it is
because my son's like a big fan of Kanye
you know and and my son is you know the
descendant of Holocaust Survivors and so
in a way how does he reconcile it with
with complicated conversations you know
uh and maybe you can't reconcile it do
you know what I mean you can't reconcile
it Kanye says unbelievably anti-semitic
staff drawing on it should be said this
is a really important thing very very
ancient antisemitic tropes one key thing
about the way what Kanye says is that um
anti-Semitism is often seen by people as
punching up so they don't see it as
racism because what they see is the Jews
are powerful so if Kanye will say things
like Jews are in control of the music
business I'm finally throwing off the
shackles of how Jews won't let me speak
about this that and the other because
they're in control I'm he then says I've
got to go Defcon 3 on them all but it
comes from a sense of this is a Rebel
Yell against a race that is controlling
us and the problem with that is that it
doesn't sound like a far right person
saying you know look at these scum I'm
just going to kill them it sounds like
someone fighting the good fight right
and that is actually
what Hitler who Kanye has said he's an
admirer of that is also how Hitler
sounded to some people but then someone
like Elon Musk takes it and he he allows
him back onto a platform what does that
you know you use Twitter a lot what do
you what does that make you think about
Elon Musk I mean
okay that's a whole other issue Beth
which is like free speech and what
people should be allowed and Twitter and
blah blah blah I mean
what I think is that
um free speech
is never it seems to me to be qualified
in all sorts of ways
um and so
Kanye being let on back onto that
platform should be part of Elon Musk
trying to you know make the platform
Less in his mind more dominated by the
progressive left but in a way you see
I'm not bothered about those arguments
I'm bothered about like what is
dangerous for Jews what is dangerous for
my children but is Kanye West doing that
I think he's doing something no
obviously I do think it's dangerous I
think it's actively dangerous in my
documentary I did a thing where I went
back to my primary school which is a
Jewish Orthodox Jewish primary school
and told people which they didn't seem
to know that this school has to do
security drills because of the
possibility that a gunman is going to
come and kill seven-year-olds and they
and what I didn't show is they also have
24-hour Security in these places which
is true of virtually every Jewish school
in the UK Elon allows him on the
platform Kanye says what he says and
neither of them think about the actual
real life the consequences the
consequences of saying Jews are in
control Jews are making your life worse
Jews are I mean to be fair I mean Elon
must did suspend him again from the
platform and to do that but yeah by that
point yeah I mean the point is these are
very very powerful voices Kanye because
he's a brilliant hip-hop artist has got
a really powerful voice do you think
he's racist okay I think what he said is
race I think he already said is
anti-Semitic I think anti-Semitism is
racism yes there was also of course
Jeremy corbyn
um the labors aren't semitism crisis
um how damaging was that and how much
did that cause a Resurgence of
anti-Semitism in the UK
well I think that um there was
unquestionably anti-Semitism on the far
left and some of that infiltrated the
labor party infiltrated the labor party
more following Corbin's appointment
um and what I always felt which is
perhaps slightly different because I was
never one actually who believed things
like this is an existential crisis for
the Jewish community and things I never
believed that what I did believe is that
Jewish people do feel threatened I
sometimes feel threatened by this I
certainly feel threatened by the fact
that we're trying to talk about it we're
trying to say particularly some of us
whose political Homeland might be on the
left we're trying to say there's a
problem here there are some voices here
that we feel are crossing the line into
something that is sort of dangerous for
Jews or whatever and that was dismissed
when a minority says this is racist
right your job is not to say no it's not
we're not interested and there are more
important things to say can I ask you
directly did you think Jeremy corbyn was
an anti-semite I actually don't think
that's straightforwardly you know I
don't think that's straightforwardly
because I absolutely do not think that
Jerry Corbin in the front of his mind
hates Jews I don't think Jimmy corbyn
would say things that Kanye has said in
the front of his mind at all what I do
think is that he comes from a tradition
that sees anti-Semitism as a lesser evil
compared to say capitalism
right so in my mind I talk about this in
my book I talk about a little bit of
documentary say the reason from in my
mind why Jeremy corbyn can't see that
that mural of men playing Monopoly on
the backs of the world's poor might be
antisemitic is he just sees rich men
playing Monopoly on the backs of the
world's poor because he's interested in
destroying and fighting against
capitalism unfortunately it's very clear
to Jews that they all look really Jewish
and they're part of a tradition that
feels like this is a sort of Nazi
caricature of the idea of the rich
capitalist Jew so you felt that what you
that he didn't necessarily hear what the
Jewish Community was saying to him about
how that well he man the labor party
just at that point in time I would say
yes Stormer doesn't start and also the
pushback continues we know this the
pushback continues they're still he said
as well corbyn said after the highly
critical report was released about
um the scale of Uncertain in labor that
it was dramatically overstated by
opponents he was then
suspended the whip removed from him and
and kirst armor is not doesn't seem to
want to allow is not going to allow
Jeremy corbyn back into the party do you
think that's right or you sort of don't
want to get in there only because I tell
you why I don't I'll tell you why I
don't get into it which I think is
important I don't get into it because
you know in an interview about Holocaust
Memorial Day I think it's really kind of
important details and the understanding
of the Holocaust is continues and I'm
trying to help a little bit by doing
this interview what will happen if I
start talking about labor party too
great detail that becomes the thing and
again that is to do with what's wrong
with how people see anti-Semitism which
is like it gets dragged down very
quickly into this kind of politics did
you find it hard to vote labor I didn't
I didn't vote labor at the end time I've
not done that at that point in time
um because yeah because I felt I felt
overall not listened to not you know the
thing about the left right I guess and
this is very simplistic but and
obviously there's all sorts of economic
things to do with the left whatever but
as a minority the thing about the left
particularly now the identity politics
is such a thing is that it should be a
sanctuary you hear the beating drum
we've talked about it it's getting
louder and louder a far-right
anti-Semitism if you're another minority
you might hear the beating drama the
type of racism so who are your people
who has your back it's got to be the
left because they say essentially this
is where we will care and this is where
we will fight and we will be allies to
you if you feel that your struggle your
threat is not being taken as seriously
as others you feel alienated okay and
that's what happened to me
but will you go back now yeah yeah okay
well look let's go go back well I'm not
a member I've never been a member of any
particular person I'll vote for them can
I just say one other thing about the
labor party actually just come back to
him and I didn't want to which is one
thing that you dear here a lot is that
Corbin did a uh various investigations
into it I think the chakra party reports
and then Morris in the Ford report yes
I've also interested in the fact that
any I think they were into different
things but they were primarily into
anti-Semitism what was any other
investigation into racism would involve
the a member of the minority heading
that report would it not
generally I can't imagine a report into
anti-black racism now in which we're not
was not a black person at the head of
that report that would be he was
intensely racist but shammy chakrabarti
is not Jewish and Martin force it is not
Jewish
so what's that about is there a sense in
which you think that's well I think
there's a sense in which a Jew would be
seen as biased and again that's a Jews
don't count phenomenon because that's
not thought about when other types of
racism were investigated like even the
much criticized Sewell report you know
that was headed and involved people from
the minorities concerned I want to talk
to you a bit about
um your Jews don't count both your book
annual documentary and there was a very
interesting aspect in it in that about
relating to the Holocaust that you
suggest that the sort of focus on the
Holocaust can also Master sort of
anti-Semitism you're talking about can
you explain that a bit David well all
I'm talking about that is that I think
that
um like as I mentioned earlier that
people can sometimes imagine that the
Holocaust is the be-all and end all of
anti-Semitism and then what it is it was
the culmination of centuries of
anti-Semitism and there's also a
slightly subtler point which is a woman
called Dara horn who's written a
brilliant book called people love their
Jews pointing something out in my
documentary which is that sometimes
someone Kenya has not done it he's
refused to do it someone who publicly
says something anti-semitic if they do
decide to apologize they'll be taken to
somewhere like the Washington Holocaust
Museum and they'll see images of the
Holocaust and then they'll do their
apology and her point is that sets a
very high bar for anti-Semitism that
suggests that the killing of six million
Jews is what anti-semism is anything
less than that doesn't really matter and
I agree with her about that yes so it so
it becomes
trivialized almost well it becomes both
trivialized and gigantized because it's
like I experience what you might call
you know there's uh a website that was
very successful for women called casual
sexism right yeah I think I experienced
casual anti-Semitism practically every
day I see care but I don't bring it up I
think I do bring it up sometimes but I
bring but a lot of time you think like
well
people think it's not the Holocaust
which it isn't but that's not the way we
think about racism now there's also the
powerful documentary where you apologize
to the black
um former football Jason for racist
sketches about him in the 1990s when you
wore a black face what
how hard was that to to do that or what
did that teach you did you have an
Awakening over that that it was a sort
of casual racism as I became more aware
of racism directed against me yeah um I
talk in the documentary and in the book
about sketches yeah on shows about me
that made me look grotesquely Jewish
yeah it's something that I've seen that
as well as being her or whatever upset
by that or thinking this is weird this
really clearly racist thing I am guilty
of the same thing and that brought it
home to me over time over much too much
time that I should apologize to Jason
Lee and I did apologize Jason Lee in
print and uh in in and I apologize for
all but then I when I did this
particular documentary I thought
which is not a complete opportunity I
had before I should go and film a
face-to-face uh apology and thankfully
Jason was up for doing that and it was
really really difficult he didn't in any
way let me off do you feel terrible yeah
I felt terrible yeah totally felt
terrible
but the end of it
was two hours and uh we only showed a
bit of endocumentary although I think
you can see the whole of it on his
podcast
um at the end of it I went up to him
afterwards this isn't on camera yeah and
I just said look sorry again and thank
you for seeing me and he just went he
just shook my hand and said no it's done
now
meaning we've done it now and we can
move on
which is important for me and important
for him
it must have been no it was difficult
yeah it should be difficult you just
this is a slight kind of sort of
tangential
question but bear with me I mean just
because also at the height of the 1990s
lad culture you you talked about
um pornography you you your flatmate
Frankston described you as a connoisseur
of porn as your view of that changed
over time you know that the celebration
of that is something you now repudiate
because it's kind of for some women
quite offensive to them I'm just saying
like the Journey about kind of some of
the sketches you made in the 90s some of
the things you may did in the 90s around
sort of comments about pornography if
you don't mind on that as well depends
what you mean about that so you see I
think the truth is in the detail so a
lot of the stuff that I did back then
which I wouldn't do now in a way just
because it wouldn't be age appropriate
um but also
I would defend some of that stuff
because a lot of it is about my own
you know
whatever it's like part of my comedy
in a way what I do now as well but it's
only about my comedy was of confessional
and being sort of absurdly over honest
and over sharing or whatever I did a
show but then called the too much
information at all and for me but I
understand how other people would
disagree but for me a lot of this is
about me putting my
um sharing my sort of failures my warts
and oldness on stage and part of that
was porn part of it was all sorts of
things all sorts of
bad behavior now
how much of that is for some people now
that won't be exercised and I use the
word like in exorcism by comedy
so some people know it doesn't matter
that you were you know saying it was you
being you know whatever uh it's you're
still getting laughs out of it you're
still getting sympathy out of it but
that's
I personally think that
that if you can find a place of honesty
about who you are in comedy including
stuff that now we might consider to be
unacceptable that's often an interesting
place to be but I wouldn't do that stuff
anymore and I agree
that
certainly that the quantification of our
culture and about the incredibly the
flooding of again to do with the
internet the flooding of our culture
with pornographic imagery is not a good
thing yeah because for some women they
think the the
pornification I think women don't well
they don't of course I agree with that I
agree with that so I guess it's I guess
okay it's very much from when you yeah
I'm going to say something else if you
want this is a whole other conversation
but I was always of the belief I
continue to be of the belief that
um that you can be interested in women
sexually and not dismiss them as people
so the objectification of women that
obviously goes on in pornography I
personally think that if you think that
means that women are people who cannot
be
thinking people that women cannot be
CEOs and judges and you know them as
valuable members of our society as men
if your sexual interest in the vibe
pornography becomes a diminishment of
them as human beings and it obviously
can then that's a corrosive effect of
pornography I'm just going to tell you
that that yeah then have a much
pornography I've watched that's never
happened to me
and it's got comp it's got more
complicated from the 1990s to the 2020s
right we all agree that at the end of
your documentary you express hope that
the dial is shifting
do you feel like people are being to
understand more about anti-Semitism that
that it's improving I think I and other
people not just me have created a
conversation by talking about
anti-Semitism as something that needs to
be included at the table of conversation
that everyone is having now about
ethnicity and race and offense and
identity and all the rest of it
but I see a constant twoing and throwing
of it so it's two steps forward four
steps back sometimes I mean Kanye is
quite a good example if I could turn to
that in that when Kanye said his things
and said he's really outrageous stuff
about Jewish people there was quite a
pushback and for a moment I thought oh
he's really being called out properly or
whatever but then what I noticed is a
little bit after that when Kanye was uh
had some strictures given to him by
Adidas whoever else it might be people
started saying you see Jews are in power
you see Jews are able to shut him down
it's all Jews doing this so it feels to
me it's complex and psychologists
say he's now he's now damaging a brand
we need to cut loose because he's it's a
drag on our brand people Progressive
people particularly say this which is
there's no such thing as cancel culture
there's just free speech and then
there's consequences for free speech
there's accountability so in Kenya's
case you might consider if you're going
to follow that model well accountability
involved in losing contracts you know
and all this kind of stuff but it came
with this spin which is the
accountability isn't just accountability
it appears to be something handed down
by these unseen people Jews seem to
somehow be doing that and that is not
hopeful
I'm going to try and end on a hopeful
note I think the conversation is
Shifting I do think people are more
aware which is the most important thing
of anti-Semitism and how it can spiral
into something extraordinarily violent I
think people are more aware of that than
they were and they hold it in their
minds more and part of that is without
doubt Holocaust Memorial Day I would say
if you know it's important to remember
those we have lost I do it I light a
candle as for the I light a candle for
my great uncle I light a candle for the
people I don't even know who I lost
but
I'm also trying to do something else
which is because that's about the past
which is to say there's a uncertain
future and a dangerous future and this
is where it can go and don't pretend
that just because it happened what feels
like a long time ago it can never happen
again and so I think that's the point
that's the constructive point you keep
saying this you keep reminding people
and then maybe it won't happen again
well David thank you for so much for
coming to talk to us about it today it's
a pleasure